My name is Rahul Basole.
I'm a professor in the School of Interactive Computing at Georgia Tech.
I also lead the Initiative on Enterprise Transformation at Georgia Tech,
where we study large complex enterprise systems.
My particular research area is on visual analytics and visualization and I've applied it
to many problems in healthcare.
Sure.
So it turns out that process mining is actually
a relatively old field in many other domains and health care.
Manufacturing certainly is one of those domains,
where you've had very detailed process charts on how
widgets and products actually move across the manufacturing belt.
In healthcare actually, we have a complete different process situation.
It's much more complex.
In fact, when you go into an healthcare enterprise,
it's very unlikely that you see very detailed process maps.
The Children's Healthcare of Atlanta Project actually is
a result of some of the other efforts that we've had before,
where we realized that scaling,
process mining and analysis jobs is really difficult.
In the old days, you would walk around with a clipboard and observe how people did work.
And incredibly time consuming, resource intensive.
In some cases it might take three to six months to
actually get things really accurately done.
With Children's Healthcare of Atlanta,
our goal was to reverse engineer data that already existed in electronic health records,
maybe in claims data,
to understand how processes actually happen, how they get done.
Perhaps understand how these processes fit together and understand variations in care.
Absolutely. So as I mentioned,
my research area is visual analytics and visualization.
So, really exposing the processes is really critical.
And so, what you're seeing here is a screenshot of a tool that
we've developed that visualizes these complex care processes.
On the left hand side,
you'll see a panel where you can filter
through various aspects of the patient population.
So you can focus down on elements of interest.
And you're seeing a graph and network modeling approach to understand how care happens.
The nodes represent activities and events.
And, the edges represent whether they co-occurred,
and when they actually happen after each other.
It's been a fascinating process,
because we actually discovered variations in care by population characteristics,
as well as by physician characteristics.
And the goal was really to discover processes,
identify variations and hopefully also enhance these processes.
One byproduct of this was also to understand conformance to the processes.
Many physicians have guidelines on how care should be done.
And our visualizations really revealed what happened and what didn't happen.
Yes.
So process mining,
you want to look at a population.
But sometimes that population is just too large and
there's just too much variation that happens within that.
So you want to hone down, filter down the ideas.
And so, given the advent of fhir and the ability to have access to digital data now,
we wanted to figure out how we could build a population health analysis tool.
Based on the ideas of visualization and analytics,
that could dynamically explore different patient characteristics,
by different population characteristics.
So ultimately, we built a tool called fhirplug,
which leverages the fire standard.
And, as you recall,
fhir really was not designed to look at all an entire population.
It was built really to look at one record at a time.
So fhirplug is a tool that aggregates
this information and allows you to really filter through multiple facets of that data.
So let's take a look at fhirplug here.
It's a web-based visualization tool.
What do you see on the left hand panel and ability to load your data set,
your fhir enabled data set.
And then, you can focus down on specific aspects that you want to look
for certain search criteria, a condition perhaps.
And once you've load that in,
you see five tabs at the top which actually reveals to you that it's an overview.
It's about process characteristics,
about patient demographics, as well as develops clinical elements.
And each of these tabs is fully coordinated.
That's very powerful in visualization,
when you coordinate multiple views to get a triangulated perspective on the data.
We're using across filtering mechanisms.
So, as you are filtering through one of the charts,
you can actually see what,
how it response in the other ones.
We've enabled multiple visualization charts within this,
including scatter plot and heat maps.
And this really allows the decision maker
or the clinician or also quality managers to look at their patient population.
Well, there is a lot of enhancements that we can obviously do to fhirplug.
Fhirplug right now, we tested it out on some synthetic large,
synthetic data sets, as well as in practice as well.
But we realize there's a lot of nuances,
because healthcare data is very messy.
As you scale up, there might be some issues that we
might discover that fhirplug cannot handle.
Scalability is certainly always an issue in software development.
And so the next steps will be,
to test it out with multiple healthcare sites,
test out scalability and see where that goes. Thank you.